all i care about
is getting home on home time that's what
i care about more than anything else
tick-tock star known as pissed-off
trucker has died the social media
personality's steve hull raleigh was 52
years old hey what's up tick tock
according to the kansas city star
stephen died on july 12th in kansas when
his semi truck veered off a highway and
later crashed stephen was reportedly
taken to a hospital where he was
pronounced dead and his tick tock
account appears to have been deleted
from the platform but fans are
re-sharing his past videos
we'll hold it down for you out here
brother you take care of you man
including steven's alleged final clip
posted just hours before his death where
he talks about wanting to get home
all i care about
is getting home on home time that's what
i care about more than anything else
steven had over 200 thousand followers
on his tick tock account i appreciate
all you guys on tick tock i do
y'all are good people
he shared his colorful humor and chatted
with fans all while driving a semi truck
across the country right off the floor
you can't miss it just
if you're going west take a left and
it's right there on the left
hope that helps
before it was deleted several tick
talkers apparently shared their
condolences on steven's final video a
fundraising page through
truckersfinalmile.com
was set up for steven's family the
description says donations will go
toward steven's funeral expenses in his
hometown of birmingham alabama
[Music]
you